I don't know why an attorney general
would be talking about this but Jeff
Sessions strangely and bizarrely claimed
that Nazis didn't deport Jews during the
Holocaust why is he saying this I hope
to find out in partnership with you
today in the next five or ten minutes
there's this building string of lies
about Germany from the Trump
administration yesterday I told you that
Donald Trump tweeted incorrectly that
German crime is way up the German crime
rate is actually the lowest it's been in
26 years after that Jeff Sessions was
being interviewed about the child
internment camps for migrant children by
Laura Ingraham on Fox News that program
is quite a beauty to take a page out of
Donald Trump's vocabulary and Jeff
Sessions tries to deny that what's going
on right now
with children in the United States is
anything like what was happening in Nazi
concentration camps okay that is
something that he was asked about by
Laura Ingraham because the comparison
who had been made by others Jeff
Sessions says that the key difference
between what the Nazis were doing during
World War two and what the United States
is doing now is that the Nazis were
preventing the Jews from leaving the
country not deporting them so I mean I
guess that's what counts as an
explanation in Jeff Sessions mind here's
the interview from Fox News with Laura
Ingraham and before I get to that just
so you know that I know it
during the same episode of her program
Laura Ingraham referred to the
internment camps as basically summer
camps for kids it's outrageous and
ridiculous I'm not covering that today
just not enough time but that's just
sort of part of the context of this
exact same episode of her program let's
get now to the clip of Jeff Sessions
this is how your opponent's general
sessions are demagogue in this video
let's listen I walked down that railroad
siding where the families were separated
and that's why I used that picture now
look I I know we're not Nazi Germany all
right but there is a commonality there
this is the United States
germán the United States of America it
isn't Nazi Germany and there's a
difference and we don't take children
from their parents until now Nazi
Germany concentration camps human rights
violations Laura Bush's wade in Michelle
Obama Rosalynn Carter got all the first
ladies gone back to Eleanor Roosevelt
she's apparently weighed in as well
General Sessions what's going on here
well it's a real exaggeration of course
in Nazi Germany they were keeping the
Jews from leaving the country but this
is a serious matter we need to think it
through be rational and thoughtful about
it we want to allow asylum for people
who qualify for it he had a full minute
to think about what to say he had a full
minute during which he was he knew he
was going to get an opportunity to
explain why is what we're doing now not
like what the Nazis did during World War
two and the distinction he was able to
draw between knocks Nazi concentration
camps and child internment camps today
is that the Nazis were preventing Jews
from leaving where as part of what the
US is doing is deportation this is of
course as stupid as it is false the
Nazis did deport millions of Jews from
Germany and from other countries to both
concentration camps and work camps and
death camps all over Europe and included
German Jews French Jews Jews from many
countries deported unmasked to
concentration camps all over the place
Poland Czechoslovakia Germany Belgium
France it wasn't called deportation it
was called evacuation but it's the same
damn thing and that's where I get back
to even if Jeff Sessions were correct
right by choosing to say that the
difference between Nazi Germany and this
is the supposedly a deportation 's all
he's saying is we're doing the early
Nazi stuff and not the later Nazi stuff
because there was a point before the
Nazis started the deportations that's
not very positive but why even answer it
in that way all yeah I just say is that
the Holocaust was a unique moment in
history six to twelve million people
were killed they were
taken from their homes and gassed and
starved to death you're talking about
document Paris right that's all you got
to do he could just say there's nothing
whatsoever that's similar and to say you
know the difference is back then they
weren't doing deportations and now we
are someone please write to me and tell
me history will not look kindly at this
please tell me that because if there is
going to be any saving grace in this
absolute abortion of an American
government that we're dealing with right
now I'm hopeful the only thing I'm
optimistic about at this point other
than cautious pseudo optimism about
maybe voting them out in November the
only thing that's in the back of my mind
as maybe something positive that could
come from this is that what we are
observing now is memorialized in history
that history will look back at this for
what it is which is a series of bumbling
atrocities and that it will hopefully
prevent it from happening again and if
there's people in the audience who
believe that that's going to happen
write to me and tell me that that's
what's going to happen and if you think
I'm wrong if you think that even that
isn't going to happen I'd rather know
the truth write to me and tell me that
as well I'm on twitter at des Pakman the
show is on twitter at david pakman show
and we'll be right back